[موسيقى]
الصيف فلكي وواقعي الفلكي ثلاثه شهور من
22 يونيو الى 22 سبتمبر والواقعي اربعه
شهور من منتصف مايو الى منتصف سبتمبر
والعامه يقسمونها الى بدايه وشده ونهايه
فبدايته مع موسم كنه ثريا عذب السجايا
وعوده باول السنه متى تزين السوالف واخذ
علومه وشدته في موسمي ذبحت وجمره القيظ
وهو موسم هبوب رياح السموم هبت رياح الصيف
وتغير الجو وانا ويلي في ميداني سمومه
ونهايته في موسم مرخيات الجلاائد قضى
الصيف عن جرد السبايا ولا بقى من القيظ
الا مرخيات القلايد ونحن الان في موسم
الكنه وهو موسم شده لسع الشمس مع الجلسات
الليليه الرائعه من يحب الشمس يبكيها
الغروب ومن يحب الليل يضحك للقمر ومن يحب
انسان ما يقدر يتوب لا صار هذا الحب
يسواله عمر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والاجواء خلال هذه الايام متغيره بشكل
متسارع فلها وجوه عده فهي تنتقل من وجه
الى وجه اخر تغيرات سريعه حركه الرياح
وتغيرات بطيئه درجات الحراره احذر تخاوي
منه بالوجه رجال خاوه اللي لا طحت تفداك
عينه السيف وهو السيف انواع واشكال سيف
شطير وسيف بالبيت
زينه
[موسيقى]